The Gold programming language can be
used to deploy serverless stacks to AWS
in this course. Akhil Sharma will
teach you how to code and deploy
a complete serverless stack with basic CRUD
functions on AWS using go. This is a complete
serverless stack. Right, so you're using DynamoDB
serverless, you're using lambda serverless again,
and then we'll be using API gateway again,
serverless. Now API gateway helps us
enables anybody across the world to interact
with our lambda function, right. So we'll be
deploying all these three things. From the AWS
console, right, we'll be using the AWS console,
and then we'll make settings for all these three
things. And we'll deploy all of this. And anybody
across the world can use our lambda function. So
this is more like a real world scenario. So I'm
in a terminal now. And you don't really have to
keep this project in your go route. Because it's
Golang. One point 12. And anyways, they had,
you know, go mod in it, which we're going to
do anyways, out here, go modern, it takes care
of everything. I mean, you don't have to really
do anything manually. Alright. So here, we will
say, we will make a directory first we will say,
Go server less, and YT. Alright, and we'll
cd into this. Go serverless tack YT. For yt
is basically YouTube, I'm making this project for
YouTube specifically. Alright, and here, I'll say
go mod in it. And which is basically
github.com/akil/go server less. So that's
my project. It's initialized go mod for me, go
mod is basically like my package json file. If
you're from a Java background, it will have all my
dependencies for me, you know, easily listed out.
So now what I can do is I can just open this
project up, and code editor, which is VS code,
in my case, just as a pointer, right, I'm using
windows inside Windows, I have something called
as WsL. Inside that I'm using Ubuntu 20.04. And I
use multiple different versions of open to write
Stan this for this particular video I'm using
over in 20.04. And in my open 20.0. For instance,
I have VS code setup. Alright. Now, I don't
want to install a lot of extensions for calling
because I know when I'll start typing, I'll start
writing a lot of code. I'll make some mistakes,
right with Golang. I'll make some mistakes, but
I will fix them. But don't worry, I don't have
extensions, because I don't want to like start,
you know, ballooning up my instance. Because
this is just one of the instances that I use. On
my Windows PC. For over two, I have, like 1015
different versions of Uber, right. So if you need
to go line, by the way, main.go file is your main
file right in the project. And this is how you
start to main.go file, you say package main and
you say import. And because you'll import some
packages, right? Not everything you'll have.
Inside go Lang go. Lang is very modular, you have
to install a lot of external packages, and a lot
of, you know, packages that come with coal, and
you have to specifically tell that, you know,
this package from cola. And so the the third party
packages that we'll be using will be mostly around
lambda. Alright, so we'll talk about them in a
while. And then the most important thing here
will always be func main, because that's
your entry point into the program,
right, the func main. Now, before I start
writing anything in main.go file, what I'll
do is I'll just try and create, like a very simple
project structure, I need the build folder, right,
because I'm going to keep my build of this
entire project in my build folder. And that's,
I'm going to zip it up, and then I'm going
to keep take that zip file to my lambda,
sorry, my AWS lambda console. Alright,
so that's why I need the build folder.
And I need my CMD folder, because that's where I
usually keep my main not sorry, not in the build,
but in my CMD folder, I keep my main.co file.
Alright, and then you will have a package folder.
So if you work with Golang, before this, like
the very standard kind of structure, right,
nothing, nothing new. So package will,
as you already know, will have handlers,
right handlers to handle the API's. And then
you will have I'll have a folder for user.
I'll explain to you why I'm doing
that. And then I have a very simple
validation functions where I'll keep that in
a folder called validators. validators. Sorry.
That's it. Yeah, so in validators, I will
have just one little file of Pedley like
five, six lines of code, I think. It's just
going to be as email valid just to check if
my email is valid for the user. And here in my
user, I'll have a file called user.co. Alright,
and my handler That's where my main logic
resides. So this is a very short, very small
project handlers, I'll just have two files,
I'll have API response.go, because I need this
file for my API gateway, I'll build it, you'll
understand what it is. And then it's handlers.co.
Right? Now, my user.go file is kind of a
combination of my models, and my, almost like my
controllers as well, you know, so I have handlers.
But you know, user.go file will have a lot of
code, which kind of which talks my database,
alright, directly talk to my database. So
I'll have those models like those structs as well,
at the same time, we'll have model functions,
those. So database functions at the same time,
I'll head over to your main go file. And func
main, I think what I'll do is I'll start
with this place, right, once I was taught,
get environment AWS region. So AWS region
is very important, because that's where your
lambda will go and set. Right. So with
AWS, if you've worked with AWS a lot,
you know that he has different regions, right. So
my particular AWS is considered configured with
India, which is Asia Pacific South one. So
if you have been using the CLI and setup is,
it'll be amazing. Otherwise, also, I don't
think you should have a problem, right.
But just try and just try and set up a CLI.
It's very easy, just a five minute process.
And it will be very simple for you to follow
along with all of my other videos as well,
because in my other videos, it's a
prerequisite. So how do you create a session?
So you will say session dot new session.
Now, if I'm calling this old, who is
here, right, so I need to have us here. That's the
package, right? And if I'm calling session here,
session is something that AWS lambda gives me,
AWS gives me sorry, so I'll say github.com/now.
Looking at the documentation for the AWS packages,
at the same time, you can do that otherwise,
in case you're the type of person who wants to,
like know exactly which package you're installing,
because I'm that type of person, I want to install
any extra packages, right. So if you're like me,
you, you might want to open up, just like
I've done, you might want to open up the
AWS SDK, it's called so I'll say AWS
slash AWS SDK for go, you want to,
we want to open up the documentation. And
here you'll see it will just slash session.
Alright, and to create the new
session, you will say AWS dot config
and the bracket which will be curly braces
bracket, you will say region, AWS taut
string and say that you'll
pass the region alright.
Alright, right. And then, as you know, with
all everything to do with Golang, whenever we
haven't, we get two things usually right,
we get the thing that we're looking for,
which is the earpiece session which will come
from the session function, right, or sorry,
the new session function, which is a part
of the session package that we have here.
And we get the error. So with go Lang,
you have to like keep handling errors,
and this is a very neat and clean way of handling
errors because at every stage you know where that
is coming from and you can handle it there itself.
So if there's an error just return right and
I want to create a variable called
Dinah client which for my DynamoDB and
dot new and how you create a
new client will say AWS session
perfect which you just created out here. So
you've created the session and then we'll say
lambda dot start and handler. So this you may not
understand right now not a problem. So firstly,
we want DynamoDB How do you get DynamoDB you get
it like this, it'll say github.com/aws/aws SDK go
slash service slash Dynamo DB. Alright,
so you have session you have DynamoDB and
you want AWS itself and the first place we will
say github.com slash AWS SDK co slash class.
To get this lambda function or sorry, the lambda
package, which has the Start function, you need
the Start function, or you will do is you'll
say github.com/aws/aws Lambda go slash lambda.
Cool. So far, so good. That's what I needed, you
know. And I need something called as the handler,
which we'll talk about. Okay,
for now, I'm creating a constant
called table name. Stable name is
lambda user. I'll say lambda in go user.
And now it's time to create my handler,
which is this basically. So I'm passing
by handler there. In my handler,
what I'm doing is, I have a request.
Basically, I accept some things right. And this
function, and I return some things, and it has
some definition. So what does it accept?
It accepts events dot API, Gateway
proxy. requests. So you're wondering what's
events? Right? So events is basically what?
Go Lang. lamda will give us so I'll come
here. And I'll say github.com/aws/aws,
lambda go slash events. Perfect.
And the other thing that this
accepts is star events dot API.
Okay, to a proxy response. Sorry, I meant that
this it accepts a request, returns a response.
I'm not sure what I said actually, before that.
What I'm trying to say here is that, you know,
this is a function that accepts something and
it turns something, obviously accepts requests,
obviously returns a response, right? No
complication there. That's what you want to do.
And what you will do here is you will switch
the HTTP method. So you'll say switch,
insert request dot HTTP method. So what are
the methods that you have you have get POST,
PUT and DELETE? That's all you have. So
for every single different history method,
we want to call a different function. How do you
do that? So you'll say switch. So we've already
switched, right? We already switched. It's
like, it's 830 here, so I'm kind of sleepy.
I usually get sleepy at 11pm. But somehow, I am
sleepy earlier, because I woke up really early.
I've joined this martial arts class that that,
you know, gets me to wake up at 5am these days. So
so you'll have something
called as handlers. Right?
And where will those handlers come in
from it's basically these handlers that
you want to import. So which are basically your
own creation, your you know, the handlers or your
own creations will say github.com/kill/go
server less, righty slash packets slash
handlers.
Cool. So you're saying to go Lang is that
this is my project github.com/search Go to go
serverless whitey? And say that I have a
folder called package instead of I have a
package called handlers. Right? And handlers
the file. On top of that file will say package
handlers and it belongs to the handlers
folder, then go Lang understands, okay,
this is what we're talking about. Alright. That's
the format. I mean, though, the folder name
and the package name have to be the same. Just
letting you know, in case you didn't know that.
I mean, I'm pretty sure you knew that, but I'm
just making sure right. So you have requests table
name and Dinah client Right, so you sent this to
this function called handlers dot get user, which
we'll work on in a while. So that was your case
get. Now you have more cases, right you have,
depending on the HDB method, so you have post,
you will have put, and you'll have Delete. For
post, you'll see return handlers dot create. User.
Again, you'll pass request comma, table name,
comma Dyna client. For put you'll pass written,
and lawyers dot update user request comma, sorry,
request comma, table name, comma, diner client.
And for delete, process two handlers dot delete
user. And same thing as you pass
the same things comma, Dinah client.
And after delete, you will just give it a default.
If you work with case switching case statements,
you obviously know this default, right? And try to
keep the orientation same. It won't affect it. But
just as a good habit, you know, I mean, I don't
do it many times. But I try to do it these days.
Alright. So by default, you want to call
this function called unhandled. Method,
which is again in your handlers file or handlers
package. And this is the entire picture. I mean,
I don't think we're missing anything. We have the
OS package down here, we have events lambda AWS
session DynamoDB. Yeah, there's one more package.
Actually, if you look at the AWS SDK, document,
then you want to import it was SDK, go slash,
service slash DynamoDB slash Dynamo DB I face.
Just keep these packages. And what I think we
should do is we should just say go mod tidy.
So we'll get us all the package
that we've just talked about.
And usually, like many times I do this at the end
of the end of the video, right? But this time,
I'm just doing it beforehand itself, because many
people they can start freaking out, Hey, you're
installing all these packages? If not, you've not
run the command go might go more tidy. Or you're
making so many mistakes, man while typing. Why
don't install some extensions, I've explained to
you why don't why don't install extensions, right.
So, so with Golang, I mean, what happens is that,
you know, we usually come from JavaScript
kind of a background, and then we think that,
oh, you know, if you're making all these
mistakes, and the complete program will crash, and
it will be difficult to solve it with go Lang.
Golang is very different from other programming
languages, right? Make as many mistakes as
you want. And once you run the program, Golang
will really handle everything for you will tell
you which line, what's the problem, it's quite
intelligent. Right? It's not like your regular
other programming languages like JavaScript.
So here, one thing that we missed out was to
create the data client in the first place,
right, so the client has in the variable, and the
defining the type of variable the data client is,
so what type of time they will
be. That's why we will use this
or maybe ifs, right, we'll say dot Dynamo.
Dynamo DB. API. Just make sure
you get this right. All right.
So that's your main file,
your main file is complete.
And now you want to start handling handlers. So
here, since these two files belong to the same
folder, call handlers. We wanted to both to be
package handlers. Right? So we'll say, package
handler yours. Right. That's clear. Now, I'm
hoping and after writing the package, you say
import and then you have your main function for in
this case, this the main function of this file is
called API response, accepts some things, return
some things and has a function definition.
What does it accept accepts status, which
is int and body, which has an interface.
What does it return? It returns the event start,
API gateway proxy response, comma error. All
right. For importing, you'll say and
coding slash JSON github.com/aws/headress,
lambda Gqo slash events. Okay. All we're
doing with this is basically defining
the response, right? So we'll say response
is equal to events dot API gateway response.
And the response, you're just setting the headers.
Pretty standard. Because the way we're going
to set up these headers are something that we've
already seen so many times. It's basically content
type and application JSON. So we're saying that
we're returning JSON from our lambda function,
write nothing out of the ordinary. So we'll say
response dot status code is equal to status.
And so basically, you're like 400, or 300,
or something like that. And then you'll
say String body comma JSON dot Marshall.
So you're, if you've been with Golang, you
already know it's marshalling and marshalling and
marshalling sorry, is Golang, doesn't understand
JSON on its own. So it needs the help of
JSON marshalling, which is part of this encoding
slash JSON package. And so whenever you send
some JSON, from postman into post postman, or
maybe terminal, wherever you send some JSON,
it basically we want coolant to understand it,
and also the information that Golang produces
for it to become JSON, and send it as a
response that also needs, you know, help,
go Lang itself with boats. So that's what's called
marshalling and unmarshalling. There are hundreds
of videos about it. On YouTube, you can check
it out, nothing fancy or nothing complicated.
You have to do that in, you know, almost all the
other languages, right, which are not JavaScript,
which is like basically, Java and Python, all
these languages, you have to do something like
that, right? Because any language that's not
JavaScript does not understand JSON, by default,
because JSON is JavaScript Object Notation.
So this is your API response to go. Alright,
that's it. I mean, there's nothing much going on
here in this file. But the other file in handlers,
package handlers, this is where we're
going to spend some time because
obviously, there will be a lot going on
here, right. So the main functions that
usually will be there will be based on our main go
file. So main, go File requires get user function,
create user, update, user, delete user and
anonymous method. unhandled method, sorry.
So these are the functions that obviously that
you need to create, right? So we'll say get user.
And he will say Create User. He will say
Update user and delete users. Update user
and delete user. Alright, so here. The
last function that we want to keep here
is unhandled. Method. Right? So for let's
say, if somebody uses the patch method,
because we're handling, get POST, PUT, delete,
if somebody uses patch, then we'll say that, hey,
it's not handled, right. So
we'll say unhandled method,
except some things return some things and
so, function definition. Alright, so this is,
in general, this is how your handles file is
going to be like. And what we can do is we can
work on our is email validated, valid
file So we'll say package validators.
And there's a package that you get with
go Lang. It's called regular expressions.
And we're just creating a simple function where
we just saying if the email is valid or not,
right, really simple. All it
does is accepts an email string.
And returns a Boolean, like, true or false.
We'll take a variable called Alex email, we'll use
the like expression, regular expression package.
And if you look at the regular expression
documentation, like I have in front of me,
go to the Golang official documentation and
check out dragon regular expression package,
I highly recommend you to open it if you
want, because that's what I've done out here,
in my other screen will use the
function called must compile.
And I'm going to copy and paste
a regular expression string here.
You don't really need to understand what
this does, you just get it directly from the
documentation. But if you really want to
know, basically, you're just checking if
you know the numbers are between A to Zed A to
Z, and zero to nine, that kind of stuff, right?
That's all it's doing. And it's
also checking for at at symbol.
Right. But obviously, if it's anywhere, it needs
to have an ad, right. So those kind of things,
just basic email validation check is happening
out there, do check out the regular expression
document if you want to really understand
what this regular expression does, alright.
But if you want to save time, just
copy and paste it like I just did.
And now we want to check the length of email.
If email, if another female doesn't three, or
length of email is more than 254 or
Arex, email variable, not match string.
Then you'll just return false. Right,
so this returns either true or false.
If these conditions are not met, then you return
false otherwise, you return true, that means
everything is fine. And email is valid. Right?
Obviously, if this is not proper, it's not working
properly. If length is more length is less,
we'll say that the email is not valid. Otherwise,
I will say to you can change these numbers as
you want. But I've kept them to be three and 254.
All right, change it on your test. So now we'll
go to our user.go file. And we'll just add a very
10,000 feet level, I'll just set up this file. Now
what I want should happen is that for my handlers,
like domain control, you know what that will go to
the main file to our, you know, to this function,
basically. And this function is calling the Get
User function and create user function update
user. And all these functions are, as you know,
mentioned in the handlers, right. And from the
handlers from handlers, you will call the
functions in your user.go file. And these
functions will be actually the database functions
that actually talk to the database, right. So
every function that you have here, except for
the unhandled method, because it doesn't do much,
these four crud functions that we have, they
have an equivalent function in your user.co file,
a complete like one to one function in your user
go file that talks to the database. Alright,
so let's do that. Let's create those functions.
So firstly, as you know, when we start off a file,
we import some things. And then here, I'll
also want to define some variables, some
errors that I want to define. So the functions
that I want to have here and my user.go file,
which will have one to one
relationship with these four functions,
the first function will be called I'll
call it fetch user. So that means is
my Get User function gets called My handlers.
And this function will call in my user.go file,
the fetch user function, which directly
gets the user from the database itself,
the database, in this case being DynamoDB.
Alright, so it accepts some things,
return some things and has a function definition
simple. The second function I want to have is
for getting multiple users actually, so
I'll say func fetch users. Similarly,
will look very similar. Then I want to have
a create function. So we'll have create user
and then it has update user you just have to keep
looking here and then creating these functions.
Then you have the law as well as delete
user, right, so you will come here
right, if it doesn't get deleted, then you
don't have to return anything specific special,
you can just return an error. That's why
from the return here is just an error.
Right? And that's about it. So we have managed
to one functions, all of these, but one extra
function is there is just fetch users. Alright,
so we'll see where to get where to use it.
So from a 10,000 feet perspective, this is your
user.go file, and this is your handlers file.
So what we'll do is we'll start with Nora handlers
function, and then at the same time, we'll start
working on our user.co functions. And here,
you'll all obviously, import some things, right.
The first thing that I need is net slash
HTTP. Then I need my lambda event. So I'll say
github.com/ad/aws, lambda go slash events. Now,
it's possible that I'm importing these, but you're
not understanding why I'm importing these. So you
might get confused. So now there are two ways to
do it. One is when I'm actually writing the code,
and then I use this events packet somewhere,
and then I come in come up and you know, import
it. Or I know, you know which ones I need. So
I'll just import them right in the beginning
itself. So they can use them later on. So I'm just
doing this. So try not to get confused, because
we'll actually be using these packages in just
like two, three minutes. Don't worry, you know
why we are importing them, we will reuse it. So
please be patient.
Slash AWS. Right. So these are the same package
that we already use in our main.go file.
And we'll say github.com/aws/check it go slash
service slash, no DB slash Dynamo DB I face.
Great. One thing that I need here, because I would
want to call these functions, like I told you,
right, I want to call this function. So that's
why I want to import this user package and my
handlers file. How would I do that? I would say
github.com/achill/go, server less writing slash
package, slash user. So inside package inside
the user package, we've inputted it here.
Alright, and then before I get started, these
functions I want define a very variable called
error method not allowed. Is equal to method
not allowed? And why do I need to create this?
Because firstly, we'll be working
on this function unhandled method,
right? So that's why you want to call
this function. So here, this returns and
event API gateway event. So it will say
API, Gateway proxy response, comma, error.
Right, so we will send response from
here, or it will send an error. And
here we'll say return pay API response, the
response that you want to send is HTTP dot.
When we say HTTP, we are talking about the
history package Nesta history package, alright,
status. Method, not allowed comma. Header method
not allowed, which we have just defined together,
right? That's what you're saying.
So you're saying that we have,
you know, something for get post put in place,
but we don't have something for patch, so
patch or any other method that somebody wants
to use. So if you get something like that,
like an unhandled handle method, so you'll send a
response saying that, hey, this meter is not loud.
Alright. And I want to create another variable,
but it's actually a struct, right? So it's an
error body. And I'll be using it a lot so
just bear with me as to why I'm creating it.
This struct has a variable
called error message, string.
Error comma, omit empty. Now
for your get user. You have
he accepts something and you turn something
Before I get user, what do you accept? What do
you what does the function get you get a request
right from postman, the request that you get is
part of a savings packet. So you can
say events dot API gateway request,
comma table name, which is string,
comma, Dyna client, dot Dynamo DB API.
And what does it return? returns the
response, obviously. So we'll say events,
dot API gateway, proxy response, comma, Irish.
Straightforward. And actually, this, these two
things, right, was going to accept and was going
to return is going to be used by all of the
functions. So what you do is you just copy
and you just paste it here for
CREATE USER for update user, as well.
And for delete user as well.
Awesome. So we've done a lot of heavy
lifting. Now, I want to start working on the
function definitions for
these all these functions.
Right, so the first thing that you'll say is
email, request dot query, string parameters.
So if you've guessed, what's happening here
is you want to get the user but by using the
email ID of that user. So for my request,
you will have your query string parameters,
which will pass an email and that we're
going to capture in a variable called email.
And then we will check the length. So we'll
say if length of email is greater than zero,
then you'll get a single user. So we'll say user
dot fetch user, which we've just created together,
right? We have not created the definition. But
you know which function I'm talking about. It's
in my user package, which has been imported here
already. So fetch user is going to take the email,
table name and donor client.
And I'm going to capture this in the result, or
the when there's going to be an error. And if
there's an error, I'll handle the error.
So I'll say if error not equal to nil.
Return API response has to
be dot, status, bad request.
Comma, or body. So everybody's a struct
that I've already defined. And in our body,
I want to pass AWS dot string error dot error.
And otherwise, you'll say hello, DB dot,
everything is okay. So we'll say status. Okay?
If everything goes well, and you'll
pass the result from this function.
Now if if you want multiple users,
you'll say user dot fetch users say
same thing, they will name a client.
And what you will do is, you will again, use
result and error to capture the values coming from
this function. And if there's an error, and you'll
check if error is not equal to nil, you will
return the API response, saying HTTP dot status,
bad request because there's an error, right?
And you'll send the error body, just like
we did earlier error body is a struct that
we've already defined. That's the error body that
we're sending, which is basically JSON. And here
the error body. Inside that, we're going to send,
you're going to send a WS dot string, header dot.
Got it? But if everything went well, and
there was no error, then we're going to return
API response and HTTP dot
status. Okay. Commerce result
So the basic gutsier get user.
Now what we can do is we can
work on our fetch user and fetch users both
of these functions in our user.co file.
Or we can work on our CREATE USER function in
our handlers. So I think I'll do the former,
I'll work on fetch users, and I'll work on
fetch user, let me just check if everything is
recording, yes, everything is recording perfectly.
I just need to keep making sure otherwise, you
know, I end up making a long video when nothing
has recorded. And that leads to a big problem.
Alright, so before I do anything with
users, I want to first create a user right.
So like I said, this file is a mix of
that model file that you usually create,
where you define the structure of how the user
is going to look like. So I'll say user struct.
Email. Now, since this user struct is small, and
we don't have multiple stocks, like if this was a
e commerce, for example, then you would have had
users and orders and you know, all those different
like products and so many different stocks,
right. So you'd have to have like a model
separate Models folder for all these different
models. And then you'll have, you'd have,
you know, database functions separately,
and controllers or something like that,
right. But since we don't have that, we have a
very small project, which just has users and users
all itself, it's a very small struct, because
you just have email, first name and last name.
You don't have too much here, right, you can
combine controllers and models into the same file.
Now, email is going to be a string
which is going to say JSON. And you
say, like this JSON email, because
for Gulags purposes, it'll be emailed with
a capital E, whereas JSON where it's stored,
it's going to be emailed with a small
e. So you need to pay a telco like
that, you know, there are two versions
of it one, the JSON version, the another
is the version that Golang understands,
because Golang does not understand JSON,
as I've already told you. So that's why we also
have to use some marshalling and unmarshalling.
To get it to understand and interact with JSON.
Alright, so you'll have first name and last name.
And then what we'll do is we'll
create our fetch user function,
what does it accept. So if you actually go to
handlers, you will see the fetch user function
accepts email table name to a client. So we'll
say here, email, and table name, which is string.
And your Dinah client, which is of type, you
already know that dB, I face dot DynamoDB API.
And it just returns a user. Obviously, I mean,
you fetch user, you return that particular
user or return error, if nothing works out.
You define a variable called input. And
it's of type DynamoDB dot get item input.
So we'll have to define the key based on which our
database function will run to find that particular
user. And you already know that the user will be
formed for the database based on the email ID. So
we take an email id, you take an email ID, and
then we want to find the user that's associated
with that email id. Alright, so straightforward.
We'll say DynamoDB dot attribute value.
And we're going to say email because we want
to run a query on email. So email is equal to
s equal to AWS dot string, dot, sorry, inside
that bracket will pass email. Now the string
is a function that is given to us by AWS package
Aerospike. It is something that we'll have to
import out here. All right. And similarly
with the DynamoDB. So we'll have to also
import the DynamoDB package. So come here on your
import, and firstly called encoding slash JSON,
because like I told you Golang does not understand
JSON by default. So you'd need encoding slash JSON
package to use the marshalling and unmarshal
like functions and I need the errors package
also. Then I want to get my hands on the events.
Now we'll be using it soon. To send responses and
the usual ones. As you can see, I need DynamoDB
and I need AWS. So let's get those ones. So I'll
say AWS slash AWS SDK, go slash AWS and also
github.com/aws/aws SDK go slash Dynamo DB.
And what I'll also do well also
get this particular package.
Yeah, let me do that for now. So
I'll say github.com/aws/aws is
a case called slash service slash, Dynamo.
dB slash Dynamo DB. I face. All right.
Now coming here, you've already
passed this. And after this bracket,
you need to specify the table name in which this
function is going to run. So we'll use the regular
string function again, to pass the table name.
And after this bracket, you want to use your
data client to finally start getting the item.
Input is this basically the query that
you created, right and get item is the
function that you get an error client. And
you will capture that end result an error.
So, standard practice, if there's an error,
we'll have it on the header soon return nil
for the value and will return errors
dot new error failed to fetch record.
So you must be wondering, Where's What
is this error come from? Probably never
seen this error, right? Because this is
a new error that I've created on my own.
How can I create my own errors, I can
create my own errors like this. So error
failed to fetch record is
equal to fail to fetch record.
And similarly, I can define any errors that I want
in this variable defined as a variable, right?
So you've, you know, created a query that is
similar to MongoDB, right, you've created a query
based on the email, because you want to search
for that email so that you can retrieve the user
and you've run the function get in get item for
DynamoDB. And you've passed the query to it,
and you've received that in something
called as result or you received an error.
If there's an error, you handle the
error. But if the result is fine,
and nothing really happened, then you
would do something right. But before that,
we will create a variable called item
and it will be basically a new user.
And here you will say error is
equal to Dynamo DB attribute.on.
Martial map. Okay, so DynamoDB attribute is
another. By the way, if you have not opened
up the DynamoDB and AWS SDK, go, documentation, do
that, because I have it open on my other screen,
you can do that as well. And then
everything will make a lot more sense,
because these are actual packages inside
that main package. Right? So I'm using those.
And once you go through the documentation, you
will understand where to use, which one, are you
or if you really don't care about that, you can
just keep following along with what I'm doing. But
I just recommend that you just read it because you
know, everything will make more sense. Here I need
this package right done, what do we attribute?
This is helping me unmarshalling the user.
So first, let me write the
whole code. So I'll say result,
sorry, not here. He'll per record
will say result, dot item comma item.
And this error if this error is not equal to nil,
what we want to do we want to return nil comma,
errors dot new error failed to on Marshall record.
So you must be wondering what's happening here,
right? When you get the data from your DynamoDB
using the get item function into result. You
want to unmarshal data into an actual user,
which the front end can understand as a
JSON basically. So you use the user struct
and and you don't take that in a variable
called item. Right? So item is basically
a variable of type user. And then, you know,
you want the data that's coming from your
result or item, you want that to be unmarshal and
brought into item so that now whatever has come as
JSON becomes, you know, the type, which is user,
which is understood by go Lang, but and it's
captured in a variable called item. Right? So
I've tried to explain to you every single line,
in case you don't understand it, to check
out what's marshalling and unmarshalling.
Alright. And if you have any, like, if you still
have any confusions, you can just put it in the
comments below. I'll sort it out for you. But
it's nothing very difficult, right, we just
taking what's coming from DynamoDB,
the JSON, and you're on marshalling it,
to make it into a struct, right? Which is of
type user, which has email first name, last name,
something that can be understood by ko lang. And
you're capturing that in a variable called item,
which is obviously of type user, right?
That's struck that we have defined.
This is standard practice, I do this in all
my other videos as well, in case you're new
to this channel, I have hundreds of videos
on ko lang, you can check all of them out.
Like literally hundreds of videos on Cola,
right? Check them out, build projects with me.
And you'll understand very everything
very easily. So if everything went well,
if there was an error, obviously, you
sent nil and you sent the errors. But if
everything went well, you'd return the item,
and then you will return nil for the error.
Now you'd want to also work
on the fetch users function,
though, plural fetch users function. How do
you do that you are passing table name there.
As you can see, here, you're passing given him
an ANA client. So Duolingo has been passed,
which is obviously a type of string to
pass 10 Nine, a client which is of type,
you already know, Dynamo DB, I face dot
DynamoDB API. And you return multiple users.
How you doing multiple users, you return basically
a slice of users, when users is the struct that
you've defined, right? So you're using a struct,
you're making a slice of all those users,
and then that's what you're returning. I hope that
makes sense. If you don't know basics of like,
of Kulang, like slices and structs, then I highly
recommend you check out the basic tutorials before
you get more confused. So I want to use a function
by the DynamoDB gives me it's called Scan input.
To get access to a table name, which has AWS dot,
string, and table name that we are already
passing here. Right. And he will say Dinah client,
thought scan and you want to scan the input, the
query that you just created. So here, as you saw,
we had a more elaborate query, because we had
to get a particular user with email. But with
fetch users, you just getting all the users, you
don't have a specific query that, okay, you know,
for this email, get a particular user saying,
Give me all the users. So you don't have any
query as such, you're just passing the table name.
So that's when your diner client, but can you just
pass the input, that's it. And scan is like get
all, you know, you can say that. So if you've used
that MongoDB, it's, you have find, find all
something like that. Here, you just have scan,
find and find one you have
in MongoDB. So you just have
scan, alright, scan and get it. So you're doing
scan to get all the results. And you're going
to capture that in a variable called result. And
then you will obviously, if you have an error, you
know that standard way to handle errors is like
this. You'll say return nil for the value when
you return an error. She'll say errors
dot new error, failed to fetch record.
And, again, like we did out here, item will define
item, right? The item here is not just a user,
it's a slice of users, multiple users because
we're getting all the users from our database.
And, again, the same thing that we've just
done here. We'll do the same thing here.
So we'll say or do just copy the whole thing
actually. Copy and paste. But there's only one
more little change instead of result
or item. You'll have result dot items.
Because obviously from AWS, you'll get multiple
items, multiple users, that's what you're getting.
And you're returning your item. And
for the error, you're returning.
Make sense. So we've done quite a bit, right,
we've already done the Get User function and
get user function had fetch user and fetch
users two functions from your user.co file.
Now there are three functions left here, and three
functions appear because we've already taken care
of the unhandled method function, you don't have
to anything more here. So just three functions
left here, three functions left here. And all
the other files are kind of complete. Right?
So if you reach this far, congratulate yourself,
because you've come you've come a long way. Right?
So now let's start thinking about how our
CREATE USER function is going to work. Alright.
So for the CREATE USER function,
let's let's start building that.
There's actually not much happening there. All
these functions, right? Create User, update,
user, delete user, like, they're all going to
look very, very similar. So going to say user,
because you know, you want to call the CREATE USER
function, the user package, so we'll say user dot
create user, which is this function,
that's what you're calling,
right? And you're passing it three things
request, table name, and a client makes sense.
Nobody will respond to this function returns, you
want to capture that in a variable called error,
sorry, result, and you will get an error
which will be captured an error. And you know,
the process from here, if there's an error, which
means error, not equal to nil, you will return
API response, HTTP dot, status, bad request,
comma, error body and what will be the URL
body. Everybody in this case, by the way, is,
sorry, the struct that we want to define right?
So was there in the body, it's AWS dot string,
with a single or sorry, string, e RR dot error.
Comma. Okay. And you'll return API
response. HTTP dot status created.
Comma result. So if that means if there
is no error, everything goes well,
then you will say he should be
dot status created. Alright. And
that's about it. That's it, actually, that's your
CREATE USER function, there's nothing more to it.
Alright. And then for your update user function,
very similar. You'll obviously call the user,
just like you did here, user dot create, user
here, you'll call user dot update user method.
So we'll say, update user. And you'll pass three
things request, table name and diner client.
And you will capture that in result comma,
header. And then you'll check again, if error
is not equal to nil. return an API response has
to be dot again, status, bad request, comma,
error body inside the body. Again, the
same thing, it was a string or a dot.
Alright, but if everything went well, if the user
did get updated, then you'll return API response.
And you'll say SDP dot status, okay? That
everything went well, and you'll return
the result. So that means what's happening,
these two functions CREATE USER update user
is that these two functions are being
called. That means a lot of the logic
the main logic is going to happen in these two
functions, right? Because not much happened
in the handlers. Similarly, let's work on our
delete user function. Here. You'll say user dot
read user, insert request, comma, table
name comma Diana client. Here also,
though, the only thing you will learn from here is
the error, right? If the user didn't get deleted,
you will turn the error. You don't need to return
the result and result from the delete function.
So if the result is not equal to nil, you will
return API response. You know by now what we're
going to say we're going to say says bad request
and we're going to also send the error body
which will have AWS dot
string And the error itself.
But if everything went well, you
would want to return the response with
status, okay? And you will
return nil for the error
okay
so that's that's about it.
And yeah, that's it, I think the entire file is
complete. Now, we don't have anything else to do.
I've also gone through the AWS SDK documentation,
I don't think anything else needs to be
done in the handler. So everything looks alright
to me. And now we will have to work on our
user of go file and all these different
functions that exist on a user.go file.
For your CREATE USER function, we're all
it's going to accept depends on what you're
sending from here, which is request a preliminary
client. So here, you'll say request, events dot
API gateway proxy request, comma table name,
which will be string, and then a client,
which will be you already know, there
might be a face dot nanodegree API.
So what is it going to return, it's going to
return the user that has been just created,
or an error. So here, the first thing
that we'll do is we'll create a variable
here, which is of type user user being the
struct that we will define that means you will
have email first name and last name. Alright.
So let's start from there. Now we'll use you,
why'd we create this variable you is because we
want to capture what's coming from postman. So
from postman or from let's say, the terminal
wherever will send the JSON of the user with
the email, first name and last name. And
that data needs to be unmarshal into you,
so that Golang is able to understand it and also
perform any operations on it. So what do you want
to do is we want to use the JSON encoding slash
JSON package to call the unmarshal function.
And what you want to do is you want
to pass the request dot body to it.
Comma ampersand you if error is
not equal to nil, and also here.
He called the right syntax for the if statement.
And if error is not equal to null, then
we'll return nil, and we'll return something for
the errors. We'll say error, invalid user data.
But we don't have this error here, right? We don't
have this error error fail to unmarshal record.
We don't have error, invalid user
data, we just have error fail to
fetch record. That's all we have defined.
Now let's define all the other errors.
Let me define all the other errors that I'll need
in this entire file and the beginning itself.
So we'll say error failed to unmarshal
record is equal to fail to unmarshal. Record
and error and add error and valid user
data is equal to and valid user data.
invalid email also will be there and valid
email is equal to invalid email. Then we'll have
good not Marshal item and
could not delete item so.
Then we'll have could not put
item so we'll say Could not
Dynamo put item as equal to code not
Dynamo put item. And user already exists.
user does not exist, or the user does not exist.
So why do I need all these errors? Obviously,
by now you would have understood, I'll just give
you an example that when creating a user, right,
if we check if that user already exists, then
we don't need to create that user. That's why
we need this kind of an error. And if you want, if
you're updating a user, then or deleting a user,
we can use this, that user does not exist. So
I trying to update that user, right? That's
why I'm just thinking about all type of error
functions, I'll need error statements I'll need.
So depending on that, I've just created
them. So going back to your create users,
right here, now, we will start
validating the email. So we'll say
validators dot validators is the package that
we have created together, right, this one.
And the function that we created in
that package was his email valid.
And you is the variable that you define. And
now after unmarshalling, the request that you in
the body body is of the request that you got from
let's say, postman, or from the terminal as JSON.
You captured that in you. So now you can now
go Lang can easily understand you because it's
unmarshal, right? It's not just one and more,
so you can access you dot email. And you can
run the validation function on it. So here the
spelling is wrong. Should I when is email valid?
And you'll return nil, comma, errors,
dot new error, invalid email. Right? And
how how the reason why I created this error is
because I want to see if that user already exists,
right? So if the user already exists, then you
don't need to create it. So we need to throw an
error. So we will check if the user already
exists, right? So I won't put that comment,
actually, I was just trying to show you. So
to check if the user actually exists, you have
to run the fetch user function, you will say u
dot male comma table name, comma Diana client.
And to capture whatever comes from
this function in current user,
and we won't handle the error,
so I'll put a blank there.
So if current user is not equal to null,
that means there is this user exists, right?
If current user is not equal to null, and length
of current user dot email is not equal to zero,
then you return nil comma, errors
dot new error user already exists.
And so all of this if the user
exists, but if the user doesn't exist,
he will just say that user right,
so how do you save that? So first,
to save that, obviously, whatever you
now have in you, you want to start
want to start marshaling it right? So
that DynamoDB can understand it now.
So you will say Dynamo DB, attribute dot
Marshall map, you and you'll capture this in AV
and you'll check for the error. So if there's
an error, we will return nil. And errors dot new
error could not Marshal items which you've already
defined, we've already defined this error right?
And now, you want to start creating your data
that you will be sending to DynamoDB. So how would
you do that? You'll say DynamoDB dot put Item
input item is Av. Comma. table name is AWS dot,
string table name. And finally, you'll see
Dana client dot put item, and you'll send
this input that you've defined here. So
yes, missed the is equal to sign by mistake.
Similar to fetch users, right, you created this
input, and then you call the ANA client function.
Similarly, you're doing that the same thing here,
you're calling the put item function. And you'll
capture that in a blank actors blank variable or,
and, or you will get an error from here. And if
error is there, then you will just handle it very
easily. You'll say return nil, comma, errors dot
new error, could not timer put item right here
faded this error already. But if everything went
well, you just want to return the user are nil.
Awesome. So this is your CREATE USER function.
And now you're left with update user and
delete user. Everything else you've taken
care of right, the handlers are go file
is complete API responses complete as
as an email validator is complete,
and may not go as complete.
And I think for our user file, we have imported
all the packages except for validators. So you
need validators. So you'll say github.com,
the validators package that you've already
created? We talk I'm talking about that one.
So we'll say go serverless yt, slash PKG slash
validators. It will also check what else
am I missing for handlers? I think I've
already imported user. And I don't need
any more packages. For API response.
I don't need more packages. For his email valid,
I don't need anything else. My main.go file,
probably, I might have missed something. So it has
handlers has always even slammed on AWS session
DynamoDB DynamoDB is, so everything is proper,
based on the AWS SDK, go right, check out this
documentation, you will know why I'm importing
these packages and how I've used these functions.
You already know that because you've been building
it with me, alright. Then we'll come here,
again, back to our user.co file. And let's
start working on the update user function.
So what does it accept, accepts request, which is
of type events, and thought API gateway requests,
comma, table name, which is string comma,
Dinah client, which is of type DynamoDB, I face
dot DynamoDB. API returns a user the
updated user. And, or fine, I mean,
or it sends back an error. And we're going to do
a lot of things which are going to be very similar
to the Create User function, which is basically we
create the user. First we created the user, right,
which is the variable u, which is of type user.
And we're going to unmarshal, just like we did,
we're going to unmarshal the request body that
you get. So request dot body, comma ampersand you
so by mistake, yeah, so I have to
close the bracket here, because
this is together. And this is this variable view.
Okay. And her nautical tunnel, if you don't want
to follow along, you can just copy and paste
this part, right? I'm not copying and pasting
because this syntax might be new to many people.
Because it's DynamoDB, kind of working with
DynamoDB. So I'm writing everything by hand.
If you want to copy and paste, if
you're very comfortable with DynamoDB,
go ahead and do that. You don't need
to, you know, practice along with me.
Then you want to fetch the user and see if that
user even exists. So you will say your email
comma, table name comma, data client. And you
want to capture that in current user Adding on
a check or the current user. So if current user
not equal to nil, is exactly what you did in the
create function as well. And length of
current user dot email is equal to zero
then you'll return nil comma errors
dot nao error, user does not exist.
So for the CREATE USER function, we were
checking for the user associated with that
email, because we want to see, you know,
that is really exists, we don't want to
add that user. But for update, we're doing the
reverse, we're checking for that user. Because
only if that user exists, we can update
the data for that user make sense? And
exactly the same things will do, because now you
want to start. So now that the user, you know,
if the user doesn't exist, will throw an error.
But if the user exists, then you want to start
updating the table with the new data. How do you
do that? Whatever you've unmarshal right now,
from JSON to unmarshal, to something that Golang
understands, now you want to start marshaling it
to something that DynamoDB understands.
So you already know what you want to use,
you want to use the marshal map function. To pass
you to it, because you've just done marshaled.
And which packages is a part of so it's
part of the Dynamo DB attribute package
we will capture it in a variable called
AV or we'll get an error. And now we can
easily handle the error. So if error
not equal to nil, return nil comma,
errors dot new error could
not Marshal it, this one.
Really, really straightforward. Now you just
want to create your input item and then you
want to just call it and a client function,
only two steps remaining. So you will say
input is equal to ampersand Dyna, more dB, dot
put item input, and the item is equal to Av
comma, the table name will be equal
to AWS dot string. table name.
And the last thing is you'll use Diana
client dot put item and you'll pass the input
and if error not equal to
nil, nil comma errors dot
new error could not Dynamo put
item return ampersand you come on.
Soon now even my update function is complete
everything looks okay. And all I want to do now
is run the Gomati command to get all
of the packages that are not there.
So I think it's taking a while
I can't find my phone anyways.
So while that's happening in the background, we
can start working on the delete user function.
So as you can see, it's all installed. I had
a couple of issues actually. As you can see,
and most of the issues were because I had a couple
of spelling mistakes here instead of SDK added an
S KD you know, so a small small few mistakes I had
made. Just make sure you get these tight. You can
easily get them on AWS SDK go documentation or
if I put a mostly I'll put this code on GitHub.
So you can just pick it up from there. Alright,
make sense? Just pick it up from there instead of
typing in all yourself because I made a couple
of mistakes. So it was it was taking a while.
But now it's install all these packages. So then
your user.go file, everything works perfectly
right? Like we don't know if it works
perfectly but everything looks perfect to me.
And all the packages are in place. All you need
to do now is work on your read user function,
which is actually the most actually the like
the easiest function. So it takes request,
events dot API gateway request, comma
table name, which is of type string client,
which is a type already know, you already
know that. Dot DynamoDB API. Alright.
So what you want to put in the function
definition, you want the email of the user, right?
So request dot, query string parameters,
and the parameters, email, then you will
create your input to the function which is of type
DynamoDB. Hen dot, delete item input, item, input
star DynamoDB dot attribute.
Value. Basically, you're passing the email, and
then finding the user and deleting the user with
it associated to that particular email. Right?
Nothing complicated. So you will say AWS dot
string. And you pass email to that.
After this, you'll say table name.
AWS dot string, pass the table name.
And now that you have your input ready,
just like we've done all other functions,
you take the data client, you call the DynamoDB
function, which is delete item in this case, and
you pass the input to it. And put basically has
your query for deletion, which is the email ID.
And you get the error. If there was an error
will return errors dot new error
could not delete item. Perfect.
Otherwise, we just return
null, nothing. Basically,
that means that the user has been deleted.
Now, I'm sure there are a lot of errors.
Because I'm not using any type checking extension
or any go Lang extension, right. So there will be
a lot of errors here. So I need to start solving
them one by one before I deploy it to the cloud.
So to find those issues, and to fix them, I'll
head over my terminal. And I'll head over to the
CMD folder and has a co build main.co and starts
giving me errors, right? So it says on this file,
line number eight. Yeah, I can see the issue,
it has to be doubled. Right. That's what
makes it the or operator. So you will run the
command again. And now you will get all these
nice headers that we were expecting, right? And
now we want to go start solving them one by one.
So starting from line 37, all the way to line 145
too many errors. So when it says too many errors,
that means that even after you solve
these, it will give you many more errors,
right? So this is why I don't really, you know,
use extensions, because Because Golang takes
care of everything, it tells you which exact line
which part, what you're missing, you don't like
it's a no brainer, right? You don't have to apply
a lot of brains just solve these issues, just like
go Lang once you do, and everything will run. So
that's why I'm so chilled out all the time, man.
So if I go back to your code, on line 37, what
could be the issue is that I have not put a comma
here and comma here. basic syntax issues, right?
That's what it says it says basic syntax issues.
Here also you need to put a comma. And let's
keep putting commas wherever you know, I think
it will need commas so this needs comma here,
which is line 58. In my case, you can check it
out where you know, it is for you. For CREATE USER
again, I'll just put a comma here just to be sure.
And I'll put a comma in the input part which is
this. Alright, and in the update user function.
Again, let's go to the input area. Here I've
put the commas or haven't seen any issues here.
And for delete, definitely you need to put a
comma here as well as here as well as here. So
now if we run it, a lot of the errors
have gone away, right? And now you have
some other errors. There are some syntax
errors also, like for syntax errors, and one.
This one was that you're not able to
refer to this function. So let's try
and fix those as well, at the same time.
So let's hover over back to our code. Let me
see the line first line says 88, line 88, blah,
blah, blah, blah, blah, yes, M is small, whereas m
should be large. What was I thinking? Am I stupid,
you know, that I was not able to? That I didn't
make them, you know, large, because obviously, the
function is martial map with the capital M.
Right? So this just means that no matter how
stupid you are, go, Lang takes care of everything,
right? So you don't need to be the smartest guy
on the planet. So let's look at others stupid
mistakes. So 108 comma missing? It's a syntax
error. Super simple, right? It's even telling
you expecting comma, right? I mean, how obvious
can edit statements be? And then people, you know,
tell me download this extension? I, I don't have
done it an extinction man. Go Lang does everything
for me. And missing statement after label wonder
if I wonder if I miss you statement after label
blah, blah, blah, blah, blah? Yeah, obviously,
the physical sign is off. And then 147 147. put a
comma here, right after 147. And then unexpected.
Yep. Found it. Now let's run it. Now. Let's
see some more errors. Yes, so it found some
more errors. And now you have to go to Line
Number 66, and 76 and 140. But these are not
syntax errors. So here, you will have to think a
little bit as to why the there's an error there.
So head over back to your
code on line. 66. Lines 66.
Yeah, so it says, let's look at the error it
says, cannot use results dot result or items.
And something something something
to do with this function called
on Marshal map. That is because you're receiving
items, not item, you're receiving multiple items,
right? So you can't use unmarshal map function
here, you'll just see use unmarshal list of maps.
Super simple, man, super simple. 36, line 76.
Alright, it says blah, blah, blah, blah, blah,
request dot body. See it says
request dot body undefined.
And it also says does not have body with capital
B. Right? I mean, you don't, you can be the
stupidest person on the planet and fix this issue,
because you just had to make this be capital.
Right? So that's how intuitive go Lang is. And
then you go to Line Number 140. Line Number 140.
I mean, I can guarantee you that you can't do any
like something like this with any other language,
right? It says there's a problem with
this function, obviously, because there's
a spelling mistake here. Parameters.
Everything is fixed now. And now let's
see. So it gives me another error. It says
unmarshal. Just off map is wrong. Yeah,
because I made mistake. Again, it should have
been unmarshal list of maps, not map. Awesome.
So now, now that your user.go file is sorted
as an IT first shows you the syntax errors,
you've solved them, then you solve the logical
errors. And now it's giving you some issues
with the handlers file right handles.
It's giving you all these syntax errors,
we'll solve them and we'll give you some
logical errors. We'll solve them as well.
And then we're good to go. Right? So we're on
the right path. Now let's go back to our code.
So whenever your code and start from
line 19, line 19, put a comma here, line
for it to fall to put a comma here, it was saying
it's accepting expecting a comma from you, right?
And line 54. Comma, line 59 Blah,
blah, blah, blah, blah Pratama.
Line 62. 60 and 72 and 66 for comma 32, comma.
All right? Now you start getting the real
errors, right, the real errors. So, line 22, we
just solved this issue on the other file line 22
Because the spelling of parameters is
wrong. And now you're going to worry about
line nine, line nine. So one thing to notice is
that it's line nine, but another file API response
would go. So open up the API responded, go file.
And here I can see there's an issue. Alright, I've
fixed the issue. It was basically to do with those
brackets. And now it's starting to show me issues
with may not go file, which is what I want. I want
to fix the main.go file issues. But on line 44,
line 44. Let me see what's happening. Okay, yeah,
I can see it, I can see the issue, it's basically
all the cases have to be together. And by
mistake, I'd written this outside the bracket,
also the switch bracket, and I've included
inside. So that error should also go away.
And now when I do this, it's created the goal
build may not go file for me. So let me see if
it has Yeah, I can see the
main file, I just have to
move it here to my build folder. And I've hit the
build file, without any issues, no errors, right.
So now let's start the deployment process. Before
you do anything else, you need to first create
a zip file. So you'll just come here it will say
zip minus gr M and build slash main dot zip. From
build slash main. So build is your folder main is
the build that you've created for any folder, and
build slash main dot zip will be the zip file
using the zip function. Maybe in your Linux,
you don't have zip, you'll have to install it
using sudo. apt get install zip. So now if we
check here, we can see the main dot zip file in
my build folder. And now we ready to kind of start
uploading it on lambda, or ADA plus lambda. But as
remember, as you remember, I told you that I have
Windows installed on that I'm running WsL on that
I'm running this open too. And on top of that I've
built this folder, right? So I need to be
able to access this main dot zip file from my
windows for my windows to be able to install,
like upload it on my AWS code and lambda lambda
dashboard. So for that, I'll do something.
So to in order to help me to do that,
I have to run this command explorer
dot exe. Dot. Now hopefully it should
open. Yeah, it has it has opened up the
Explorer at this location
for me, and I'll copy this.
I'll put this on my desktop. Awesome. And now
I can start to deploy this on my AWS console.
So you want to start deploying, but there's one
thing I wanted to change is this table name.
So I'll keep this table name same as my, the
name of my program. Go serverless righty.
Okay, just for consistency sake, because we'll
have to create this table in DynamoDB. And
let me just search. If I was using the other table
name, so you'll just control Zed. And we'll just
see if I was using this table name
anywhere else in any other file.
This only place there's only one place I was using
it. So here's the table name has to be changed.
It will say go server less writing. Okay, and
now is when we start deploying. So log into
your console and head over to lambda. You have
to just create function go server less writing
server using Golang one point x I think we'll have
to change the execution roles create new role from
AWS policy demo This option is what you have to
select, and the roll name, go serverless, righty
execute from the templates, you have to choose
Simple micro service permissions create function
successfully created, right? Now
you want to change the handler.
So as you know, our main, the file that we'll
be uploading is called the main file. That's
what our build is called right. So we'll
have to change the handler to mean upload
the zip file and upload it, go back to AWS
and go to DynamoDB. Can you will click on
Create Table Table names table
name is what you selected here
go server less whitey. Simple, right? Because
we've kept everything the same name so
and primary key. So it says enter the partition
key name, I think this is the primary key here
is the primary key. The primary key in our
case is email. Which is string, obviously.
And everything else is same. And we
can just create the database active,
it's now active. So now we can proceed to the
next stage, which is configuring your API gateway.
So head over to your API gateway.
Create API. Now to build a REST API.
Protocol, let's test select new API here.
And now you want to put the API name,
which is cool. Server less ID.
And you then create the API.
From the Actions to create method, select any.
And here you'll select integration type
lambda function. And check this use lambda
proxy integration. And you have the name of the
lambda function here, which is go serverless YT.
And you have to also have to ensure
this is checked default timeout.
Now we need to deploy our API.
So from actions deploy API
select new stage, stage
name of staging and deploy.
So this is your URL that you get here.
Which we will be using right now to test.
So let's test it out. I'm, I'm expecting
some errors to be there. But not a problem.
Let's clear our screen. And first, we'll have
to build this command. So just give me a second.
So here are my four commands. And obviously, this
is post which is creating a user this is get all
users get a particular user by email ID. And this
last command is for update. Now we can use postman
or you can you just use curl which are the same
thing right? And you set your header header and
you tell it was the request which is post
and the data that you send which is email
which is my email address, my name my last name
and this is the the unique link that I just got
this Link is the unique link that I just got
from my invoke URL. Okay, so I'll post these,
I'll post this command somewhere, how do I post
it? Now? Okay, so I'll do is I'll upload this
project on GitHub, and then in the description,
I think I'll just post these commands so that
you can just copy and paste them quickly. I
think that will be the best option. Or you
can just use postman when given you have to use
these commands if you don't want to. Alright.
And similarly, for the update, you say it's
request, but you have the new data is going
to find email based on that, because email
is our primary key, as you already know,
and this is my API link will follow
commands, I need one more command, which is
the Delete command. So I'll change that to this.
So you will get all these in the and
API gateway documentation on how to
call these API's, you can get that
also. And so I'm just copying those,
and I'm just changing those commands. Alright.
So what we'll do now is we'll try and test it.
I'm pretty sure that we some error
will fail. But let's do it anyway.
Oh, so it worked. It worked.
Alright. So it created this user,
which is amazing. Restaurant the second command.
Sorry, this command
is not copying and pasting.
Now returning the get all users command.
So we'll get all the users only one user
is S, which is getting that. And then we'll
get the particular user. particular user has
this email id, it will get that user also for
me, because there's only one user right now.
Yes, so that's also working. And now we will
work on our put function. So sick, it's taking my
email address and changing my first name to
lalala and last name to blah, blah, blah,
right? So it's done that you update is working.
And now we have to work on the delete function.
So if the delete function works, it won't
return anything. So we will check if
that user is still there, so
we're getting all the users.
That means delete work, because it's an empty
array, right? That same user is not there anymore.
Perfect. So that means everything is working. I
hope you enjoyed this tutorial. It's a long video,
I know there's a lot to follow. There's a lot to
learn there. And I hope you really enjoyed it. I
hope you learned a lot in this project. And very
soon I'll have I'll have one more project coming
up with serverless tag, but it's a little more
advanced, we'll have multiple lambda functions,
we'll have CloudFormation, we'll have you know,
those CloudFormation scripts. So everything will
be through YAML files, and then AWS CLI. And we'll
also use AWS, Sam for the entire setup. So that's
going to be really complicated. So make sure
you've done the AWS lambda, you know that video
and you've done the serverless video. And then
you read a little bit more about how serverless
works and all the different technologies. And
that will really help you in the next upcoming
video. There'll be slightly longer actually much
longer, and they'll have like way more complicated
project, right. So the point of that is where this
is like a monolith serverless project, right? That
will be serverless microservices project, there'll
be API gateway CloudFormation. They will be a lot
more technologies. I will use AWS, Sam for all
the writing all the configuration files. Anyhow,
so I hope you're enjoying it and do subscribe to
the channel if you haven't already. And there are
hundreds of videos on go Lang on my channel, check
them out. And I also keep sharing some nice advice
on you know, your development career. So keep
watching that as well. Alright, so see you and
connect with me on LinkedIn. There's the LinkedIn
link in my description box below. Thank you